hello everybody and welcome to episode
two of my payto playay flipping series
uh we're going to use only the grand
exchange to buy and sell to get to 100
Mil uh again the rules are I have to
renew my membership with the money I
earn um so we have about 10 days left on
the membership so we still got a good
amount of time here and we're up to 3
mil so I think we're doing fine uh but
we'd like to be doing a bit more than
just breaking even so let's see what we
get done in this episode again we have
about 2.9 mil and some crappy items um
yeah so we're going to start off by I
think we're going to do the prayer
potion uh so you can see in the
background it we bought it for
3.5k and we're selling it for 3K exactly
um so these aren't traded very much so I
do undercut I don't usually undercut if
it's a highly traded item but it's kind
of fair game when it's not traded that
frequently like I only bought 300 of
these in a day um so we'll we'll
undercut a little bit so yeah we'll buy
about three 400 of these I really good
margin on those so those should be good
okay and for the second item here I
think we're going to do the Mystic hat
you can see in the background it has
like a 3.5k margin it's only like a 10K
item so that's really good um we're
going to buy a 100 of them for about
11.5k and with the last little bit of
our money I think we're going to buy up
some bow strings uh we were going to do
these earlier for a larger amount but we
got the Mystic hat instead so we'll buy
uh 3,000 these at 189 and they had about
a 6gp margin on it so that's pretty good
and we'll come back when uh some stuff
sold
okay so we're checking back in here uh
we just did a quick bow string flip and
we still have to sell off most of the
stuff we've bought so far um so we got
6K and all the bow strings so that's
like 15K so not super great but it's
very quick uh but we just have to
readjust some of the things here uh the
Bandos Pages we totally sold all those
off finally so we got 1K Prof on each
one which is pretty [__] uh but we got
those and uh we bought all the potions
which is actually exciting uh so we got
for just over 3,000 and we got some of
these hats as well and not nearly as
many as I was hoping um so we'll deal
with the hats first I think um so
basically what I do is I just buy one
more hat for Max price just to check the
margin uh which has crashed okay um but
by buying one more you're not really
losing any money because you're going to
be selling them right away anyway so
it's good to use that to check the
margin again assuming the item is not
extremely
expensive uh but yeah we drop these in
here for about 1,200 and get like 400
profit each which is pretty bad now
however the potions very good though the
margin I just check it here has not
changed at all still at 3500 to sell
them for um and we bought them for
3050 so that's 450 GP margin on it which
is nice uh times 400 is giving me like
let's get my calculator uh 180k which is
really good we'll have to see how long
these take to sell though not really
sure who's buying one dose PR potions I
understand why You' sell them but I
guess I guess people might decant them
but yeah so we'll leave these in for a
while and we'll find a couple new
items okay so next up I think we're
going to try flax uh we were going to do
the bow strings but they're very high so
we'll do the uh precursor to the bow
string um so yeah has a 2 GP Marg which
seems really good um you can see right
there so we're going to start off by
checking the historical values which is
pretty good uh six is pretty much as low
as it ever gets uh next up we actually
need to check the buying limit uh cuz
I've never bought these before and since
they're really cheap we'll definitely be
able to hit the buying limit uh so to do
that you just can go to the wiki now not
all of them are here but some of the
more popular items will be um so got
flax so yeah it's 13k buying limit um so
we'll buy more than 13,000 since we'll
be gone for a while so we'll just do a
multiple of 13k um just cuz it's a
little easier and it gives you more even
amount you'll get uh because of the
buying limit so I think we were going to
do 26k but I think we end up doing
52k and for the last item here I think
we're going to go with the tlogs I think
I had a 10gp margin on it so we bought
them for 120 and I think we sold it for
110 yeah 110 uh so that's pretty good um
tlogs I've done a lot in the past they
do fluctuate quite a bit but I think
we'll give this a shot and uh hopefully
we don't lose any money on it um so we
cannot afford that many so we will go
somewhere lower than 20K we'll do 10K
and uh hopefully we can get a 10 GP
margin it okay we'll be back when some
stuff's
sold so we got really lucky on these te
logs here we'll have a look at in a
second but we managed to get 30 GP
margin on them and we got the majority
of the logs we managed to buy um so
we'll start with the uh flax really not
much on there we got two GP and we made
about 6K in total didn't give any flax
uh the Mystic hats were useless like we
said we didn't get almost anything on
that but the te logs we got 220k you can
see the difference there just because of
the fact that they've Rosen up uh I
think there's an update coming out or
something and prayer potions we actually
managed to get 176k as well we got and
bought and sold all of those for about
440 GP profit on each one of those so
really good uh we made about 400k on
that flip so that's really nice
hopefully we can do a couple more like
that
so for the first item here we're going
to do the one do prayer potion again uh
still has a 450 GP margin on it uh which
is really good they do take a while to
sell but they buy pretty quickly uh so
we'll get five of these and uh find some
more
items okay so we have what the hell is
going on there look at te logs they're
at like
400 maybe I should pay more attention to
patch notes what the
[__] okay so we're g to do pine no look
at the pineapples oh my God what is
going on someone's messing with my fruit
look they're all rising up too I don't
think it's safe to buy these items
they're fluctuating so much or I should
have bought them it's too late more it's
too
late okay uh you know what we're GNA try
the pineapples anyway they're uh they're
rising up so maybe they'll keep Rising
so we'll buy them for I think it was 300
each and uh they do have a 27 GP margin
on it which is pretty nice uh if it
stays that way uh so we'll buy we're
taking a of a risk here but we'll buy
3,000 and just hope it doesn't crash on
us okay so next up I think we're going
to do the Mystic boots uh they're traded
pretty frequently and they tend to have
decent margins on them yeah we bought
them for 7200 and we can sell them
for 6,500 yeah that's pretty good 700 GP
on an item that's about 6K is pretty
decent and um they're traded a good
amount still um so we'll put an offer in
I think for aund of them and we'll just
do it for the low price
6500 and we'll just get one last item
here and lastly here we're going to do
the gothics page 2 uh it has an 8K
margin you can see there and it's traded
pretty frequently so it's a decent item
and uh we'll do about I think we do
between 10 and 20 like 13 or something
and uh we'll just leave this in
overnight and hopefully we can uh buy
them all all right I'll see you
tomorrow okay so we have sold some stuff
we have to redo the offers cuz they've
stopped selling pretty well um so the
pages we did sell sell all of them which
is nice uh we sold them for a 4K profit
as opposed to eight but we still got 23k
off the pages uh the prayer potions
were're kind of halfway through selling
uh We've sold 257 of them so far for a
340 GP profit so that's about 87K and
then we just have to put a new offer in
and the boots actually went really well
we sold them for about 2400 GP profit on
each one and we've sold about half them
I've sold 54 uh so it's 131k from the
boots uh which is really nice as well
the pineapples we did not manage to sell
many of those so that's not looking too
good but yeah basically what we just
have to do is re put in some of the
offers recheck the margins and just uh
find one or two more items it's a little
bit hard to see how much money we've
made on these because we've boughten the
full amount and sold only half of them
so we'll just we can look at my history
here but it'll be a little hard to
determine any of the profits but what
I've told you is what I calculated
myself uh so it's accurate okay so what
we just have to start off by doing is uh
just recheck the margins of the items we
have left uh so the one do prayer potion
we'll see here yeah it dropped down a
little bit to uh 3350 uh but we should
still make at least two or 300 GP on
each one uh which is nice so we'll plop
them in here for
3,350 or something
330 and I leave that that uh the Mystic
boots we have to go buy another one just
to check the margin again because they
had stopped selling as well um so we'll
go ahead and check that
again so yeah those have dropped down
down quite
significantly um so we'll probably not
make much more on the rest of these
boots but we've still already made over
100k on the first part so that's nice
still and the pineapples just kind of
sucked in general here uh so we'll
probably sell them let's see
for a one GP profit or 2 GP sorry uh so
we'll sell those back here and just get
our 2K okay so we noticed that bow
string actually had a 7 GP margin on it
which is really good uh it was buying
for uh 174 and I sold it for
167 uh which is really good so we'll go
and try to buy some of these bow strings
we'll use the rest of our cash here and
uh and it's decently low for what they
normally are at so this is pretty safe
uh so I'm happy I found that and yeah
we'll come back when everything's
sold Okay so we've sold off mostly
everything uh B strings really quick it
was an easy 60k we made um six GP on
each one and we got 10K of them so
that's really easy
uh the Mystic boots we basically just
kind of sold them at almost not quite
Break Even we made I think 14k on it so
we got like 300 GP on each Mystic boot
we had left and we sold about 50 of them
pineapples we legitimately sold them for
what we bought for so nothing on them uh
the pray potions were still kind of in
the middle of selling uh they are taking
forever so I might steer away from this
in the future although it is decent they
do take quite a while to sell um so if
that we're just going to leave the pair
of potions in and we'll find some other
items here so the blow strings actually
still have a really good margin on them
it's actually 11 GP now I bought them
for 176 and sold them for 165 uh so
we're definitely going to try to take
advantage of that that has a really good
margin especially for such a fast moving
item um say we plop it for 165 and we're
going to buy a good chunk of them uh
15,000 maybe a little less I will do
13,000 and find a couple more items all
right so I think we may actually do some
zra scales uh we don't really have
enough money to make this worth it but
we're just kind of testing it out since
we haven't done them much before uh so
we bought him for 157 and we sold them
for 155 that's pretty standard to have a
2gp margin on those Zar scales uh they
buy and sell super quick you'll hit the
buying limit for sure before you make a
lot of money but it's still really nice
every four hours you can flip 30,000 of
them or something yeah so I mean
realistically you can get 60k every
couple hours just from flipping them
which is still pretty good uh but we can
unfortunately not afford that many so
we'll buy 6,000 and I think that's it
we'll just check back when they've uh
sold all right we're going to put a
little cheeky offer in here for the
third age long sword um actually so yeah
we'll put in for w GP and uh I'll come
back when it's uh bought okay so we have
boughten the bow strings and the scales
unfortunately we didn't get the third
age long sword that was surprise uh but
on the bow strings we got actually a 19
GP margin which is insane unfortunately
we only had about 3K of them uh so we
made 50 7K in the bow strings the Zoro
scales same thing had a 3gp margin which
is good but we only had 6K of them uh
which still n to this 18K on the Sol
skills um so what we have so far is we
have about 31 50k in coins and about
700k worth of prayer potions so we're
going to end the episode here uh we're
at about
3800k 3.8 mil sorry or 3.9 mil somewhere
around there uh so we made about 800k
this episode which is pretty decent um
hopefully we can still get a little bit
more going forward because we're on day
eight now so we're getting close to
halfway and we are at just four mil so
we should be good but we would like to
be kind of exponentially getting more
money so we're not going backwards here
um but yeah thanks for tuning in guys I
hope you enjoyed if you want to see more
just hit that subscribe button and I'll
see you guys in episode 3
[Music]